encuentra el volumen de un tanque cuya
base tiene un área de 30 x
3x cuadrada más 30 x 5 metros cuadrados
y una altura de 8 x 5 metros aquí
entonces podemos empezar por dibujar
nuestro tanque no sabes que incluso este
tanque podría ser no sé como un cilindro
entonces tenemos por aquí nuestro
cilindro digamos que estas dos rectas
son paralelas deberían de serlo y aquí
en la base tenemos algo así y si este
cilindro fuera transparente en que
veríamos tal vez unos puntitos por aquí
ok
este es nuestro tanque y lo que nos dice
es que tiene una base que tiene un área
de 3 x cuadrada más 30 x + 5 que ésta es
la base del cilindro la base de nuestro
tanque y esta base tiene exactamente la
misma área que esta cosa por aquí
mide 3 x cuadrada más 30 x más 5 bueno
por otro lado también nos dicen que
tiene una altura de 8 x menos 5 que esta
altura por aquí
recuerda que soy muy mala dibujando pero
que estas dos líneas tienen que ser
líneas paralelas y rectas y entonces
esta distancia de aquí desde el piso
hasta lo más alto es de 8 x menos 5
ahora si lo que queremos es encontrar el
volumen de este tanque o de cualquier
objeto tridimensional de esta forma que
es como un cilindro entonces lo único
que tenemos que hacer para encontrar el
volumen es tomar la base que
es x 30 x 5 por la altura entonces
tenemos que multiplicar por 8 x menos 5
aunque hay porque así es como se define
el volumen de cualquier cilindro así es
que es simplemente tenemos que
multiplicar estos dos polinomios y eso
es lo más sencillo del mundo lo único
que tienes que recordar es cuál es la
propiedad distributiva ok aunque esto
podría verse súper complicado o sea
simplemente tenemos que pensar en todo
este paréntesis como si fuera un solo
elemento ok si tuviéramos aquí en lugar
de este polinomio un 7 que es lo que
haríamos pues tomaríamos ese 7 y lo
distribuir y amos dentro de este
paréntesis o sea que agarrar y amos ese
7 y lo multiplicamos por 8x y luego
sumaríamos ese 7 x menos 5
aunque tenemos 7 x 8 x + 7 x menos 5 y
eso es exactamente lo que vamos a hacer
aquí vamos a tomar todo este paréntesis
y lo vamos a multiplicar por 8 x tenemos
aquí que esto es igual a 8 x por todo el
paréntesis que es 3x cuadrada más 30 x
más 5 y ahora le tenemos que sumar menos
5 por todo el paréntesis menos 5 por 3 x
cuadrada más 30 x más 5 ok y listo ya
aplicamos la propiedad distributiva una
vez aunque bueno todavía no hemos
terminado por completo porque aquí
todavía tenemos otros paréntesis
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
volver a aplicar la propiedad
distributiva aunque vamos a tomar este
8x
lo vamos a multiplicar por cada uno de
los términos de este paréntesis y lo
mismo con este lado tenemos que
multiplicar el menos 5 por 3 x cuadrada
por 30 x y por 5 y sumar todas esas
multiplicaciones aunque entonces nos
queda 8 x x 3 x al cuadrado esto es 8
por 3 24 x al cubo más 8 x x 30 x eso es
240 x cuadrado más 8 x x 5 eso es 40 x
más
- 5 x 3 x cuadrada eso es menos 15 x
cuadrada más menos 5 x 30 x menos 150 x
y finalmente menos 5 x 5 es menos 20 5
muy bien ya ahora lo único que nos falta
es simplificar este polinomio que
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es buscar
el término con grado más alto que en
este caso es x al cubo y lo ponemos en
el principio este 24 x al cubo 24 x al
cubo y ahora buscamos todos los términos
que tienen x al cuadrado que es el
siguiente grado más grande entonces
buscamos por aquí y aquí tenemos 240 x
cuadrada y tenemos menos 15 x cuadrada
entonces tenemos que tomar estos dos
términos y sumarlos y tenemos que 240
menos 15 es 225 entonces aquí estos dos
términos se convierten en 225 x cuadrada
y ahora pues vamos con el siguiente
terminal
buscamos términos que tengan nada más
una equis aquí hay uno
y hay otro entonces nos queda 40 x menos
150 x y esto es menos 110 x y finalmente
llegamos al último término que nos queda
nada más menos 25 menos 25 que pues
podemos pensar que es menos 25 por x a
la 0 porque x a la 0 es un 1 entonces
este término es un término constante
pero listo ya encontramos el volumen de
este tanque el volumen de este tanque es
24 x al cubo más 225 x cuadrada menos
110 x menos 25 que es lo que nos queda
de multiplicar el área de la base que es
este polinomio por la altura